des écrans des partis qui se joue à la
dernière seconde bienvenue sur un
tournoi de heath porte sur le jeu heures
stone a rendez vous organisés l'hôtel de
ville de versailles ce jeu est considéré
aujourd'hui comme un sport à part
entière et un jeu de cartes donc ça va
se rapprocher plutôt des échecs je
dirais il ya les jeux vidéos qui sont
beaucoup plus dynamique beaucoup plus
basé sur la et dans le sud est
vraiment un jeu de réflexion qui est
donc un jeu créé de l'univers de world
of warcraft qui paradait de plus au
grand public et le but ça va être avec
son deck salut biotech de cars 2 30
cartes d'être le premier à réussir à
détruire son adversaire ce jeu a
également ses champions dans ce tournoi
vers seyant pouvait trouver michael
lozada liasses mavericks l'un des
meilleurs joueurs français en activité
il s'est lancé dans la discipline il ya
quatre ans comme un athlète de haut
niveau
j'ai pas vraiment l'appeler sport mais
il ya beaucoup de similitudes c'est à
dire qu'on s'entraîne beaucoup on
analyse nos matches être capable d'être
concentré tout le long d'un match et
même de plusieurs matches quand on doit
jouer plusieurs sur une journée c'est
pas toujours quelque chose facile même
bien boire entre les matchs etc
ces deux réflexes que tout le monde m'a
pas et qui sont très importants qu'on
veut faire la différence au plus haut
niveau
et comme pour tout sport de haut niveau
cette discipline a de nombreux fans
certains étaient présents à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles m comme c'est aussi
des gens qu'on rencontre qu'on peut voir
à la fin
à l'ordinateur en sur twitter en
streaming on a un peu de contenu comme
ce que l'on connaît peu leur histoire
alors n'est d'autre qui raconte extra et
donc c'est vraiment sympa de les voir
aussi en vrai à la mairie de versailles
comme aujourd'hui
au total au rendez vous a réuni encore
cette année plus de 500 passionnés une
nouvelle édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine